Chuyếny梅 có cái tổng qua đi, nó nóng ở cái dạo này toàn bism dất ná rộc
Mình nó ngọt thiên nhiều vầy cái chiến tất vý số học của tổng hợp
Đặc đó họ thì các bột kiểm đường tập việc tập nhiều kian sức hoen dần
Mlook aquí có cả 1 quân xác vậy tổ xa xuất
1,3 quân xác ổng hợp và nếu đồ xa xuất dễ troc em vượt tập tình th Phase Ngày diy測
Nhật 1,3 1 đồ xa chào vài toàn 2 thì dưới tuy ri dạy phóng rất là sức xác
Đó, tại 1 trong những nhà được kiểm đồ xác này cay tổng ở trên kèm đi
Nhe, B ef nghe chá, các bạn vừa gãi không?
Nhe chá, đều không!
Tây ra vừa rồi, coi đây, các đường thuật thời gian xFORE còn nhờ, các bạn không đồng được được trong binh thường...
...crant đừng bi.
Đừng bi ăn được quá!